all right hi thanks for coming back from
lunch so quickly
he's a sound okay yeah okay great so
after lunch you know with dark Bracken
or slides I had to turn off the light
lights kind of so if you fall asleep I
will walk up to you all right so this is
talking about the state of techniques
for solving lodging in imperfect
information games and this being
tremendous progress in the field over
the last 12 years and so if you haven't
followed this field this should be a
treat this is joint work with a lot of
people I'm gonna show the different
segments with the names of the people at
the beginning of every segment and this
is so this is an overview talk as they
asked me to do
all right so in incomplete information
games that we're talking about they're
like this so there's a game tree like
you'd have in chests a but you also have
these information sets where the player
whose turn it is to move does it know
which node in the information set he's
in you also have nature move nature can
make moves that's a white note here and
nature doesn't play strategically but
stochastically and you could have any
number of players some of the results
are for in player games some are
specific for two player zero-sum so here
this would be two player zero-sum
there's the red player and the blue
player and then this nature alright
tackling such games well the techniques
I'm going to talk about are domain
independent so they apply to that class
of games in general and techniques for
complete information games like chess
don't apply here at all because of the
information sets challenges are unknown
state uncertainty about what others and
nature will do and most importantly
interpreting signals and avoiding
signaling too much so I need to
understand what the somebody's action
signal to me about the private
information about my action signal to
them about my private information and
Nash equilibrium is a great definition
of how you should take those signals
into account but it's just a definition
you have to marry it up with algorithms
to compute these solutions to make this
operational so most real-world games are
of course multi-step and incomplete
information like negotiation multistage
auction sequential auctions political
campaign allocation military
vacations next generation cyber security
and security games so million is gonna
talk about security games that he's done
a lot of working typically there you
look at the Stackelberg model one guy
moves and the other guy moves to world
ends maybe in the future we can have
more sequentiality and that allows you
to do more do more and million and I are
talking about that also cyber security
so we've done some work on wireless
jamming and some ideas for operating
system security and so forth
and here's a wild and crazy idea that I
have medical treatment where we're doing
an application where we steering
evolution and biological adaptation
using computational game theory and
opponent exploitation techniques there
I'll be happy to talk about that more of
life poker has become really the
benchmark I wouldn't call it an
application but the benchmark for
testing these different types of
algorithms and different groups work on
the same problems build on each other's
results publish and get better and
better over time
I'll show you these graphs over time and
it's been truly amazing how much
improvement there's been in poker
there's hidden information of course
uncertainty about future events you need
deceptive strategies to play well and
the game trees are very large here's an
example from TB this is heads-up No
Limit Texas Hold'em you see a little bit
of this on TV but most of it happens
actually on the Internet ranging from
tiny stakes to huge stakes where
individual pots can be over a million
dollars alright so here's the leading
approach for solving these types of
games first you have the original game
then and by the way this isn't giving us
a game tree it would be way too big to
give us a game tree so you could think
about that giving us a piece of paper
with the rules written out but in
completely understandable form
like to play Texas Holdem I understand
that you do for the matter if it's a
three or higher then why I should
compute right yeah I'm the abstraction
part here is about in player general
something when we get to the actual
equilibrium stuff I'm going to talk
mostly about two player zero-sum and
then I'm gonna pop back okay let me take
the three player thing at the end when
I'm gonna talk about multi player but so
far if you like to think about two
player and think about just Nash alright
so you run an automated abstraction
algorithm to get a smaller strategically
similar game then you run a custom
equilibrium finding algorithms to solve
that to get the Nash or approximate Nash
and then you model use a reverse model
to map the answer back into the original
game yeah
yeah Nash and Bayesian as are the same
thing when it comes to these types of
games so NASA is just bass Nash every
when you when you have beliefs like this
all right
lossless abstraction so this sounds like
an oxymoron the idea was that we can
make game smaller by filtering the
information a player receives so for
example in poker if you're really
receiving an ace of a particular suit
we'll just tell you that you received an
ace and we can make the game smaller
like this of course we can lose
something as strategically important
that way but we came up with an
algorithm nothing smells out
automatically all of these things that
are unimportant and gets rid of all of
that spurious stuff from the game tree
so we used it to solve Rhode Island
Hold'em which is an AI challenge problem
with three billion nodes in the game
tree without the abstraction the
sequence form LP had 90 million rows and
columns so it was too big to solve the
game's shrink abstraction algorithm is
grand in one second and then the
remaining LP had 1.2 million rows and
columns and at that time it was just
barely solvable with a little
supercomputer in my lab so we found the
exact match for this and that was the
largest incomplete information game sold
by then by over four orders of magnitude
the bigger had the biggest one before
that had 140,000 all right of course
while the lossless abstraction algorithm
gets rid of 99% of the game typically
that's not enough the remaining game is
typically still too large if you talk
about large games like Texas Hold'em
absolutely tell you did you get the
exact match right totally lost list the
exact Nash
that's like sounds sounds weird that you
can even do it but but it's basically
you can think about the game having
isomorphisms that don't matter and you
can get rid of those and typically in
poker games that's about 99% of the game
so the remaining game is 1% of the
original measuring the size of the game
the typical measures are either nodes or
information sets yeah roughly I can make
a game where you don't get anything so
there there's nothing to abstract out
they are hiding a lot yeah it's amazing
but it's true so a simple example really
trivial examples so if you start the
game with two aces
it doesn't matter which aces you have it
may later matter but it doesn't matter
right now that was a question I just
gave you an example that in the
beginning in Texas Hold'em if you have
two aces right then at that moment it
doesn't matter what suits they are it
can become it's a matter later and
that's okay the algorithm will figure
out that that that later point it will
matter I'm gonna stop the questions and
he's anybody sleeping I walk up to you
all right
so for bigger games like Texas Hold'em
you have to use mostly abstraction and
abstract more to make games that are
small enough so for example in to Limit
Texas Hold'em to play mini Texas Hold'em
where when you throw your bet you have
to bet a given amount you have 10 to the
14 information sets that's something I
can just write down into play No Limit
Texas Hold'em which is a more
and larger game you have ten to the
power of 161 notes in the info so
information sets in the game so there's
no way you can write that down that's
more than the number of atoms in the
universe and even if you had for each
atom in the universe the whole universe
within it and you counted those sub
atoms it's still more than that all
right so now we're gonna have to
abstract more I'm gonna just say what
the main ideas are from this whole
sequence of algorithms have happened
2007 to 2013 of practical abstraction
algorithms the main ideas were integer
programming meaning that you don't just
greedily abstract you're actually
planning your abstraction carefully how
many children does every node in that
straight game yet to have potential
where abstraction that's the idea that
the hands don't really just abstract
based on their value but based on how
they transition probabilistic
to the next level already abstracted
notes and then imperfect recall so
sometimes it's a good idea to forget
something that you already knew that
matters so as to be able to
computationally afford more refined
abstraction of the present all right so
the leading practical extraction
algorithm in na right now combines the
last two of those ideas and obvious so
first here's it in short what it does
there's a bottom-up path of the tree
clustering using histograms over next
front clusters histograms of the
probability transitions to the next
court run clusters which you're already
made because you're going bottom-up and
distances earthmover distance turns out
to be better than l1 or l2 which were
the early ones used in this field all
right yes okay you too smart so there's
actually a technique that you actually
do this in in a special data structure
that doesn't show this whole game tree
all right for distribution this was by
then the world's largest shared memory
supercomputer we ran the algorithms
there to generate 30 nyan 7 which is our
program that won the heads up No Limit
Texas Hold'em
World Championships among computers
called the annual computer poker
competition it's the current reigning
champion the idea here is that the
supercomputer and actually especially on
distributed architecture you can access
local memory quickly but remote memory
very slowly so what we do we want to
make sure that the game is dis jointly
distributed onto the different servers
so no information sets cut across and
then the game solving algorithm moves as
if the architecture forms a tree as well
so let me leave it at that using against
the potential where idea so here I guess
you're solving the zero-sum game getting
an optimal strategy and it worked very
well in a multiplayer game no this is
two player heads up means two players
yeah all right so no never said this
whole literature weren't kind of what
works well what works well what works
well what's a good I read years but it
was all kind of heuristic in that there
was very little theory and now we have
some beginnings of a theory here and
I'll say a few words about that
so not a game abstraction with bounds
what I'd like to do is to say it if you
run this abstraction algorithm then
solve for Nash in the abstract game that
strategy has bounded regret in the
original game this is tricky due to the
abstraction pathology so unlike single
agent settings like mdps
in games making a finer grained
abstraction can actually cause your
strategies to have more regret in the
original game the prior loss the
abstraction algorithms have no bounds
the first exception was for stochastic
games and now we can do this for general
extensive form games for both action and
state abstraction so in poker you could
think about action abstraction is bit
sizing abstraction and state abstraction
being kind of stretch all right the main
theorem here goes like this and I'm
really just summarizing a lot of stuff
into one slide for any Nash equilibrium
in that start game
any reverse snapped strategy into the
original game is an epsilon Nash
equilibrium in the original game you
have to do this reverse mapping in a
particular way which we call in
undivided lifted strategy but that's not
an assumption because we are doing the
reverse mapping we are free to pick it
where epsilon is max over players
epsilon square this is the players
epsilon and what is that well it's two
times the reward era which is defined
recursively on the game so nodes reward
errors how differs from the abstraction
if it's a leaf and you recursively
define it up the tree so that a player
knows it's a maximum error of the child
nodes and up nature nodes it's a
weighted sum then you add the sum of
heights in the game tree for that player
or the maximum utility in the abstract
game times the nature distribution error
at I J and here's a little subtlety that
we can actually do this with the nature
distribution error here which is
important instead of the player
distribution error which is dependent of
the strategies which would give us a
chicken-and-egg problem and then sum of
the heights of nature's turns in the
game tree two times the nature
distribution error at the height times
again the maximum utility in the
abstract game so if you didn't follow
that the bottom line here is that we
have on the left hand side quantities
that we can easily measure from the
abstract game and the real game so we
can just look at them myopic Lee and say
what are those quantities and then we
can tie it to Nash equilibrium here and
this is kind of weird in that how is
this possible I just told you that
there's our abstraction Pathology so
what gives
yes the question is that I told you that
that's me we make a finer and finer
abstraction the solution can get worse
because there's abstraction pathology in
games which is not there in mdps not in
any single agent setting now here I'm
giving you a bound how is that possible
yes you heard my talk before but thank
you so it is a bound so it leaves some
room for the abstraction pathology and
you actually see that in the experiments
all right
hardness results determining whether two
subtrees are what's called extensive
form game three isomorphic which is a
subroutine used in the abstraction
algorithms is graph isomorphism complete
and computing the minimum size
abstraction given a bound that you allow
is np-complete so you might said wait a
second coming to course disease issue
especially with two player zero-sum
games which are in principle
polynomially solvable
now we're solving an exponential problem
as a preprocessor how can that make
sense well it's not that hard in the
usual case and we're also working in a
special structure so we don't have to
write it to write the whole thing down
all right we also extended this
imperfect recall games so you can
actually get some bounds there and
there's actually an interesting role in
modeling so if you think about modeling
in game theory or any setting really
modeling is abstraction of reality so I
think now we had no idea when we made
our game modeling choices how the answer
is from that model then would apply to
reality but now these are the first
types between reality and modeling as
well if you can measure the left hand
side of quantities between reality and
the more at least boundary alright so
that was abstraction let's talk about
game solving and now we're gonna move
into the two player zero-sum setting
alright so here's a historical
scalability now Amy we're talking about
nodes in this slide on the y-axis on a
log scale it started by kind of the
sequence form and simplex algorithm then
moved to the barrier algorithm and
here's where the annual computer poker
competition was executed and everything
went off you see the super exponential
scalability improvement here with these
custom algorithms
and nowadays a more relevant measure is
the number of information sets now that
we have that on the x-axis and you can
see that this exponential growth or
what's almost solvable Solo put a small
epsilon really truly small not some big
approximation ratio has continued to
grow exponentially so this one the last
one which is a real data point is
heads-up Limit Texas Hold'em it's almost
solved so small that you couldn't
actually tell even if you played a
lifetime against it achievement speed
whether you're bidding it or not even if
you've got to look into its brain what's
here this is a new technique which we
call regret bit based pruning if you
know the counterfactual regret
minimization algorithm it's a new
technique for doing pruning there so
basically if any sequence is reached
with zero probability because it's
regret this negative we are actually
projecting saying okay how many
iterations will it take of CFR at least
before that regret can get back to
positive and we can skip that whole
subtree for that many iterations and
then we have a technique where we
actually go back and if the regret is
now positive after that time in one
iteration we can fix that subtree in a
way that still honors to see if our
convergence rates no no no
so this must this was in the gradient
algorithm space excessive gap technique
fast which will fast easy GT which we'll
talk about this was that these were all
CFR so these are University of Alberta a
guy from California
this is CFR from our group with some
good even top
this is CFR Plus from University of
Alberta and then this is our youth
improvement over C apart which also
works for CFR Plus this is totally
because we don't really know we've only
tried it on small games and we get one
two three orders of magnitude we haven't
done the supercomputing run of this year
but wait to see that in about half a
year so I might argue that this chart
itself is evidence that this is the
wrong measure of game complexity because
the numbers on the y-axis here are sort
of well beyond any sort of cognitive
limits of human players and the thing
that you're exploiting and all these let
me take that offline in the interest of
time I mean I I want to talk to you
about that but in this there's a lot
coming and you too alright so the
leading equilibrium fighting algorithms
for two player zero-sum now we're really
two player zero-sum there are really two
families that are totally different from
each other but they have selective
superiority so it's kind of amazing that
they're at the same level over the
totally different and have totally
different strengths and weaknesses so
counterfactual regret minimization it's
based on no regret learning this is
based on Nestor of excessive gap
technique most powerful innovations on
top of that here
each information set can have its own no
regret learner which makes makes it
possible instead of doing no regret
learning in the whole space of
strategies and sampling you can sample
it sample the tree instead of actually
doing full traversals here are most
powerful innovations smoothing function
for sequential games this is called a
props function and without the proxy
function this technique doesn't work at
all it was clear that you can actually
even make one for sequential games but
you can they end there's some changes to
the algorithm itself more aggressive
decrease of smoothing and balance
smoothing and then there's a memory
improvement which applies to all
settings where the available actions
don't depend on chance that happens to
be a feature of poker at least and there
you can use and decomposition technique
for representation to get to have the
memory of square root of original how
many iterations does this need we're
pretty bad one over epsilon squared
where epsilon is epsilon in the epsilon
equilibrium but each iteration is fast
here we going it much faster you need a
number of iterations one over epsilon
but each iteration is slow both of them
paralyze
they have selective superiority and one
of the advantages of this is that this
can be run on imperfect recall
abstractions although there are no
realistic pounds for that but at least
you can run it you can press the button
or Return button and it goes here you
can't do that because it inherently
assumes the sequence form and then here
there's a new order log 1 over epsilon
algorithm which seems a lot better than
this and it is but when you have closed
equally good room already at the end
this is much better but there's a
condition number which depends on the
game in front of that all right better
first order methods so first order
methods are gradient based methods and
egt is one example of that so far a GT
is the most scalable of those four game
solving but here's some new theory for
this so there's a new props function for
first-order methods like eg T and mere
aprox gives the first explicit
convergence rate bounds for general
zero-sum extents form games so also it's
better even superb cash classes for
which there were some and most
importantly it introduces gradient
sampling into these gradient based
techniques
so Andrew Gilpin and I a few years ago
we already did matrix sampling I've got
a little bit of benefit but nothing like
to see if our sampling schemes now you
can actually do similar kind of sampling
assets and see it far in the gradient
based techniques so this gives us the
hope that we can actually have the
iteration speed as fast to see afar
while still having the smarts of the
optimization framework of gradient based
instead of regret based and that also
allows us to run on a perfect recall
abstractions again with no bounds but at
least we can press the Return button
one other ideologist mentioned if you
have good intuitions about what the
answer should be you can actually use
that to make the equilibrium finding
faster so here's some intuition from
some ganzfried for Texas Hold'em in
games he believed that this is a
qualitative structure of n games
years play one strategy players to
strategy weaker hand stronger hands and
it should be cool it Aveda like that or
he said maybe not maybe it's like that
or maybe it's like this and that's all
that's okay we can actually put these
into an integer program and say it are
some of those cases the qualitative
guess is right and the idea behind the
integer program is that we have to be
indifferent at all of those boundaries
and the integer program is just finding
where those boundaries are and if
there's no equilibrium that corresponds
to your guess it's gonna tell you that
your guess is suck all right it's a new
idea simultaneous abstraction and
equilibrium finding so I'm not gonna go
into the details I'll just say what is
the problem that's being solved here and
how it does it at the high level so we
can't solve a game without abstracting
it first but at the same time in
principle you can't abstract without
solving because what should be
abstracted together depends on the
probability vectors at those information
sets so if two information sets have the
same probability vector those should be
pocketed together but we don't know the
probability vectors say their output of
the equilibrium finding so this is a
chicken-and-egg problem simultaneous
abstraction and equilibrium finding
abstracts and solve simultaneously so it
cuts through the chicken and egg problem
and you might wonder it okay well once
you change the abstraction you have to
restart the equilibrium finding so you
lose a lot of work but that's not the
case we have a theory of how you can
carefully restart CAFR by discounting
the iterations you have so far so you
get the good warm start and it's
important that you do the discounting
just right according to the theory
because if you're even a little bit off
turns out that in practice as well this
goes astray abstraction size
traditionally must be tuned to the
available run time so when we look at
the computer poker competition every
team does this every year they said okay
how much super comfy computing do I have
available I'm going to do my abstraction
size to that but here
the abstraction size automatically
increases over time so you don't have to
sit the abstraction size upfront and we
talked about the pathology that larger
abstractions may not lead to better
strategies but were strategies here the
technique guarantees converges to a full
game equilibrium not the equilibrium of
the abstract game all right so now
that's all I was going to say but thank
you
well we're good so far we talked about
equilibrium let's talk about opponent
exploitation now so traditionally there
two approaches there's the game theory
approach kind of what we talked about
and the opponent modeling approach so in
the game Theory approach you abstract
and then solve for approximate
equilibrium and Nash is safe in two
player zero-sum games in that if the
opponent plays something else
it can't hurt me but it doesn't
maximally exploit weaknesses in the
opponent the opponent modeling is kind
of opposite you think about machine
learning approach where you learn what
the opponent does and somehow best
respond to that turns out that in
practice in Texas Hold'em at least it
needs prohibitively many repetitions to
learn so it gets crushed by the game
theoretic approach in the competitions
also you have this get taught and
Exploited problem where I can actually
teach cost is that hey I have this
mistake in my strategy I have this
mistake and then when Kostis moves to
exploit it I'm gonna exploit him huge
and this actually happens in poker a lot
plus in a lot of other games all right
so the idea here is that let's hybridize
the two approaches so we start playing a
bit precomputed near equilibrium with
the techniques we talked about and then
as we learn that the opponent or
opponents deviate from the equilibrium
we start to adjust the strategy to
exploit them but starting from the
equilibrium instead of jumping to the
best response and this requires no prior
knowledge about the opponent it's
significantly outperforms game theory
based based strategy in two-player Limit
Texas Hold'em against trivial opponents
and weak opponents that some groups
submitted to the competition against the
strong opponents
you can just not turn it on so one
simple idea is that you just said okay
if I'm losing I'm not going to turn it
on or playing equal I'm not gonna turn
it on but if I'm winning then I'm gonna
turn it on to win even more other modern
approaches to opponent exploitation so
you could run a epsilon safe best
response which is the best response
where you guarantee that you don't lose
more than epsilon per iteration in
expectation or you can pre-compute a
small number of strong strategies and
use no regret learning to choose among
them at run time another thought he said
can we actually get around to get taught
an exploited problem can we get a safe
exploitation strategy and at first blush
it seems that you can't at all and there
were actually two incorrect propositions
in the literature so this wonderful and
but us by the way in that you cannot get
this but turns out that you can so what
is safe safe strategy achieves at least
the value of the repeated game or
sequential game in expectation clearly
game theoretic strategies are safe but
they don't exploit maximally can you
exploit more and still be safe well one
idea is that risk what you want so far
if I've won $100 I'm going around and
Epsilon safe base response where epsilon
is $100 safe or not
safe or not it's safe right you're dead
wrong safe wrong
okay it's not safe because I could have
just gotten lucky and now I it's not a
first step
criteria it's a it's an average criteria
right right so I could have just gotten
lucky and if I compromise my hundred
dollars I'm honking with my upside
booking from an ex ante perspective in
expectation but my full downside is
still there so an expectation I'm not
safe there's another idea so that's not
safe other idea really risk what you've
won so far in expectation over natures
and on randomizations in other words
risks the gifts that the opponent has
given us assuming the opponent plays a
best response in states where we don't
know safe or not I know this is scary us
anything it is safe okay so that's safe
that is safe and there are other things
that are safe also beyond game theoretic
strategies but number two is
distinguished a strategy for a two
player zero-sum Saint game is safe if
and only if it never asks more than the
gifts received according to two so any
other safe strategy has to be more
conservative than number two and this
can be used to make number two can be
used to make any opponent model or
exploitation algorithm safe by saying it
okay your model is recommending this
action is it safe according to our
definition if so we're gonna play it if
not we're gonna go back to equilibrium
we looked at the whole literature of
opponent exploitation albums none of
them were safe and number two in
addition to being theoretically the most
opportunistic it also experimentally
performs the best and also you don't
have to know that gifts exactly as long
as you can lower bound the gift set to
opponent that's giving you you can use
that in doubters okay
so that's all I was gonna say talk about
technical things except for the
conclusion
coming up now let's talk about how do
programs do against humans in poke ok so
we talked about rolled up island holder
3 billion nodes in the game tree but to
play optimally ends up Limit Texas
Hold'em this is 2 player Texas Hold'em
where whenever you bet you have to bet a
given amount 10 to the 14 information
sets so you you can actually write this
down after you've done lossless
abstraction and that's how this is
actually sold you do lossless
abstraction and then you run a new
algorithm called CFR Plus from
University of Alberta
so what surpassed pros in 2008 there's
some little man-machine competition in
no7 where puts lost and in 2008 there
was a little one that where they won
these are like maybe a couple of
thousand hands each and there was a
science paper this year where this game
was almost solved so solved one mainly
big blind per hand which is such a small
difference from optimal that even if you
play for 70 years at human speed you
will not be able to tell the difference
so what about the bigger and harder and
more popular game of No Limit Texas
Hold'em again heads-up two-player this
has 10 to the 161 information sets well
the best part is was the reigning
champion is titania save and there's
another competition coming in early 2016
we'll see what happens this actually
beat all of the competitors with
statistical significance and then we
took this and improved it to what we
call cloud eco a new beta program and
then we organized the Sprint's versus AI
event where we had four of the top ten
pros at heads-up No Limit Texas Hold'em
come to Pittsburgh play in a casino in
controlled environments with duplicate
matches to reduce variance eighty
thousand hands twenty thousand hands per
player over two weeks morning to evening
they were playing against the program
alright here's the world champion by the
way he's playing and this is literally
what it looks like here's the ai ai
nobody in the seed hears him
teachers are totally empty because they
play so fast that the live audience
can't sit and can't understand it and
but on the other hand on Twitch we had
50,000 live viewers like poker
aficionados from all over the world who
play at these speeds they were super
excited ok so here they are
number one guy in the world number two
guy in the world of three and these
other guys are actually in the top 10 as
well this guy is the one that actually
did best against cloud o'clock all right
then here's our team Ron Brown Sam
ganzfried myself this is what it looked
like on Twitch so you can actually see
all of these hands you can go to YouTube
now they're all on youtube so you can
retroactively look at the hands and see
all the mistakes and good place if
you're a poker fan the humans took it
very seriously so they had $100,000 that
they were splitting as participation
fees based on how they did relative to
each other so the Pennsylvania Gaming
Board didn't allow us to gamble so we
could never win anything even if we had
beaten the pilot so all of the money
went to the humans by definition but how
much each one got depending on a
dependent on performance so they were
serious so every morning they're
stretching they're taking care of their
sleep hygiene I think they had one glass
of red wine during those two weeks very
serious they flew in an analysis sky
from Florida that was doing computer
analysis of the hands day and night so
this was actually not really a human
team but the computer supported human
team that we were facing here all right
how did we do well the pros won overall
by 91 Milotic blinds per hand this is so
close that it's not statistically
significant at the 95% confidence level
even after those 80,000 hands and 95% is
what we use in the annual computer poker
competition mainly big blinds per hand
1000th of a big blind and big blind is
twice the amount of the smallest
increment you can bet
there have been actually two relatively
recent challenges but we're the top
humans played against each other and in
both of them the winner won by more than
the Njemanze beat us so this is another
statement of how close it was three of
the pros beat cloudy call one lost to it
and pros won nine days we won four days
of the thirteen days of play so it's
pretty close but we're still behind I
think that in a year or two it'll be
fixed strengths and weaknesses strengths
beyond what pros usually do so these are
clerical strengths if there's tiny bits
and huge rolling bets or four onto
little pots that you must never do
perfect balance so whenever it bits it
bits with a perfect balance of hands so
you can't really read anything into it
and this was very interesting that the
pros picked up on that right away
randomization so we are using mixed
strategies mixed behavioral strategies
that are not range based so even the
best pros kind of think range based and
they said with what range of hands would
you do something and that means that
they're playing a pure strategy doesn't
mean that they're always betting with
the strong hands they mix in the agile
techniques they put in some of the weak
hands into the range as well but at the
end of the day it's pure strategy well
we're not some things that considered
really bad in poker books what's called
limping and donk backing the pot that's
both of those things so it's kind of
putting questions at poker books
weaknesses
well course handling of what's called
card removal in the endgame the
algorithm for M game solving was fine
it's just that we had to use an
abstraction there as well as coarse
enough so as we can do it in 20 seconds
and that's why the humans operatives
problem action mapping where the whole
approach is that if the opponent plays
an action we have to map that action
back into our abstraction there's some
exploitability there that's not just a
function of cloud eco it's actually an
issue with the whole framework that's
being used today and no opponent
exploitation because we knew that the
humans were going to be great and our
opponent exploitation is great against
weak players we didn't turn it on at all
so they that allow them to try all sorts
of stuff against us at
we'll without any penalty to that all
right let's multiplayer poker
well this is Kostas this question boats
aren't very strong at all exceptions are
certain jamb folding games that we've
solved near exactly so let's conclude we
talked about domain independent
techniques abstraction first most less
abstraction then the best practical loss
the abstraction which includes potential
we're imperfect recall and with move a
distance loss the abstraction with
bounds both for action and state
abstraction and also for modeling and it
would be nice to marry these two things
together in the future
right now they're still somewhat
separate simultaneous abstraction and
equilibrium finding there's some theory
and experiments on the reverse mapping
how should you map the opponent's
actions into our abstraction if they
move something that's out of the
abstraction and then in game solving we
didn't have time to talk about those
equilibrium finding can now solve games
with ten to the fourteen information
sets to very small epsilon we talked
about the gradient based approach is
called taking CFR to one over epsilon
with the gradient pace and then to load
one over epsilon with the condition
number in front and a new framework for
gradient based algorithms that allows us
to do three sampling and all sorts of
other good things that are already part
of CFR so we can actually now maybe get
the best of both worlds we talked about
regret based pooling for CFR which is a
new thing and qualitative knowledge and
guesswork to help it equilibrium finding
and then we talked about opponent
exploitation basically one idea was
marrying the equilibrium based approach
with opponent exploitation and the other
one was a safe opponent exploitation and
there's of course more so to stop here
or we can talk about future research
direction
thank regards to the chicken and egg you
look you you left them a kind of puzzle
way you Center the chicken egg but then
how have people been doing it beforehand
if there's a chicken and eggs
Oh abstraction and equilibrium planning
you don't have to do abstraction very
well and that's basically the standard
approach which are started with so you
run some abstraction algorithm that's
not informed by the equilibrium and then
you solve for equilibrium it's informed
by these things like a potential how how
states transition to next States based
on probability vectors and things like
that even if you get that right that can
be lost
yes so you do see in small games you see
that the egt is converging faster like
it's bound once a theory bound will
suggest but as the game gets bigger the
crossover gets thrown further and
further out you do see the same shape
but it gets thrown further and further
out and that's for egt that works in the
sequence form and that's why it's so
important not to work in the sequence
form anymore
and the new stuff opens the door that we
can actually do gradient based
algorithms like egt in a3 based sampling
based setting like CFR is that going to
work we'll know in about a year I think
I mean it's working but is that going to
outperform CFR the best variants of CFR
like CFR Plus with rbp I don't know yet
yeah so so this is all one hand at a
time so cash game I mentioned a little
bit about the endgame solving for three
players Jam fold in games so for that
very special kind of endgame
we've almost exactly solver the in games
but by and large now